I've been reading this book called lol I
think the writer is Christie Deerling
and it's about her life growing up poor
and then she became this
multimillion-dollar salesperson and and
the vice president of a company she
talked about what she learned that was
the poverty mentality versus people that
break out of that and that is a
willingness to find a solution that
people that stay in a poverty mentality
Wow don't and those who break out they
find solutions they have a problem we
find a solution
that being said people creating
opportunities for themselves in in LA as
a writer it doesn't even have to be LA
but those who don't and say I don't know
what to do can't find you know I've been
submitting whatever verses those who
find a way out of that problem what have
you noticed
well the it you know I think what you're
saying is true I do think you know week
let's let's face it we can't have it all
we can't we can't be perfect in every
single area and I think one of the one
of the things I've noticed you were
talking about you know earlier we were
talking about the fact that there are
are differences in how things are done
in the industry now and one of the
things is there are a lot more people
who are who are into career counseling
as consultants and sometimes when you
get stuck and especially with writers
because it's writers are so in usually
so internal about how they they process
things sometimes it's hard for them to
become external and try and and get
things out there and to do it the right
way I know that there are several people
that that are now career counselors who
have really helped in that area to try
and bring they talk to you and find out
what it is about you that that they feel
is special and and what is it about your
writing that's meaningful and they try
to bring that out in you and for you to
use that to help you to you know with
your work and I do think that that's
something that that writers can look
into not just writers but I know actors
and actresses do a lot of times they
have to go to career coaches
to help them out with that you would
think actors and actresses you would
think that they would be very external
and very out there but a lot of actors
and actresses I've met there's a lot of
self-doubt sometimes behind them and so
every once in a while they get get stuck
that's what they they sometimes do they
go to career coaches to help them out so
there are career coaches that they that
are specialists in in terms of with
writing let's say somebody at this point
can't afford that what are some other
things people can do to create an
opportunity for themselves it sounds
like a writing group or any type of
writing group is wonderful it's good
the more people you communicate with who
are doing the same thing you are doing
means more opportunities because I've
noticed that if one person finds a
little bit of success they're willing to
share it and you know like if they get
an agent or if they if they get a
producer to read their material they're
then ready to say oh well you know maybe
I can you know help this person who has
a project that maybe that producers
looking for as I mentioned earlier that
that's what happened with one of my
clients when she was in a writers group
so I think that that that really does
help I do think it also helps if you
have if you go to different you know in
in terms of networking there are
networking groups that they have here in
in LA there's one that I think it's the
first Friday of each month and I think
it's called first Friday or something
and but they have a group where people
get together and they will say okay we
are meeting at such-and-such but usually
it's a cocktail bar or something you
know some some group you know restaurant
or something and a lot of times there's
other writers there there's also other
writers who have made it who were in
that group who sometimes come so there's
there's things like that somebody else I
know said that when they first moved
here they knew no one what they did is
they went they went and googled writer
screenwriter meet up and they came up
with a list of things and she
to every single one of those she formed
her own writers group from the people
that were of interest to her that really
she thought she made it a connection
with it she now has a lot of a lot of
friends she came here knowing no one
she's from North Dakota and she said
there was nobody in her town that you
know she she put up a little thing
saying any screen I should put it up the
local university at that you know in her
in her town and nobody there's nobody
there that that said anything about yeah
they're they're interested it's great so
she felt okay I guess I gotta move to
you know to California and so she just
took a leap of faith and she did that I
mean it doesn't work for everybody but
it sure worked for her and she now has
an agent she has been doing punch ups
she's really a great comedy writer and
so she's been doing punch ups and she's
been doing some stuff for late-night
they've tried her out doing some stuff
for late-night comedy work you know to
do writing there so you know it's it's
kind of interesting to see how people
start to make slow progress just by
being you know by the connections that
they're making I think we all know
someone that has great intentions but
that maybe they just kind of wait for
emails they wait by the phone and they
don't do anything about it what have you
seen from that sort of type that gets
them out that that they stop waiting and
relying on someone else and they and
they start making opportunities just
like the woman that started her own
meetup group and I think that's an
excellent idea
but that's kind of scary I mean that
takes a leap of yeah I get it she knew
some of the people but I mean still it's
intimidating but how what do you see
well I think the most she told me the
most intimidating thing was moving from
North Dakota up shore that's that's
scary in itself it was scary but she
figured if she could do that she had
nothing to look she looked at it about
when she went to these meetup groups
she knew nobody she figured she had
nothing to lose and everything to gain
and I think a lot of it is your attitude
when you come in if you if you are
looking for something and you really
want it you make the effort to let
somebody get to know you better and and
it does it takes a huge leap of faith
but it's
it's worthwhile in the long run for most
people who do put themselves out there
it's not easy but you know you you have
to do that I mean and there are a lot of
people who just give up and if they give
up it meant to me it means then it's
then it wasn't meant for you that that's
that wasn't meant for you but if you
stick with it something eventually is
going to happen
like I told you I interviewed over 200
these people who are professional
writers the average was 8 scripts there
was one guy who is now on staff on
television he's a really good television
writer and I asked him I said well gosh
how did you feel you know what hey you
know how many scripts it took him
it took him 12 scripts and I said well
what did you do you know like when you
reached 8 8 scripts or something he says
you know what I don't know there just
was something about I could not stop I
mean it became like I'm gonna do this
and he just had to do it and he just
kept writing and writing and he finally
got to that 12th script and I and I saw
I said to him I said she I'd like to
read some of those first 10 scripts and
he goes no I don't think he want to and
I said well yeah but I'd like to see
what they were like and he goes you know
what I I don't let anybody read them I
said well do you still have him because
yeah I haven't been a drawer in the
bottom of my desk and I said well why
are you keeping him then and he said
it's to keep me humble because how could
I even think I look at those tonight how
could I even think that I was a writer
when I read those 10 scripts
I mean that's it just amazed me and this
guy's quite successful I mean he makes
six figures a year you know as a writer
and he's doing quite well but it took
him that long and so it does it you have
to have that determination you just have
to do it you know if you you can't just
say well you know I'm oh well I guess
it's not gonna happen
it's like you have to do I always tell
people it's like you're knocking on
Hollywood's door they aren't gonna
answer if you're you know you're not
going to get that door open
if you don't and
let's give them the answers or you don't
tell them anything what it is that you
want and it's not just what you want you
have to show them what you have so want
and have are two different things you
know you can dream about it but you have
to make the dream come true dreaming
about it and not doing anything about it
all right that's that's the difference
between success and failure and I some
of the people that I've seen that I've
known for years who now are doing quite
well in the business it's because they
deserved it they really stuck to it they
just couldn't help themselves they had
to keep writing and they believed enough
to themselves that they said you know I
got to do this a lot of times they had
to take two or three jobs in order to do
it a lot of times they family and
marriage and family came and you know
and went in between all of that because
I asked one of them untime his wife was
a teacher and they have twins and so he
had to be the one to stay home and take
care of the twins which is not easy and
I asked him how did you do it and get
your assignments in on time and he said
he basically had to stay up at night and
do it he would set the alarm he'd go to
sleep at 10 o'clock he would get up at 3
o'clock in the morning do the feeding
and then he would work for 3 hours
straight until he got and he gave
himself you know that he would have to
write so many words you know or Saurus
or how many scenes or whatever it is and
that's how he did it he just stuck to it
and he said there were times when he
would sit there and he would be waiting
and waiting for those words to come and
it wouldn't and he finally would just
start writing down random words and
pretty soon he would come across
something he said it would just like oh
wait a minute that word oh ok and then
pretty soon it would start to flow and
he says he doesn't understand it to this
day he just knows it happened and he
said he just that's what he he did but
he always made sure he said even on
those times when he felt like he
couldn't do it he just felt he had if he
wasn't going to write he was gonna sit
there and stare at that page and just
write random words until something came
to him
because he felt he had to at least
physically be doing it or physically
typing it up for him to be able to feel
that okay even if I don't come if I
didn't I'm not sitting here with an idea
in mind I'm just gonna keep typing
something until something strikes me and
that's literally how he said he got some
of his assignments done he some of them
worth some of it was trash you know he
didn't you know he would type for an
hour and nothing would come up and then
all of a sudden something would click so
I think he just felt that he had to do
it he forced himself to do it and it
worked for him and he had the weirdest
hours but it worked for him
you